the broadcast is now starting all
attendees are in listen only mode
good morning everyone and welcome to
investor expo
show for june 4th my name is anna and
i'll be your host today
we are having a great lineup of four
speakers for you
michael waltzes eric gephardt
wally allopathia and dr barry burns
this session will be recorded and sent
to your email
please take a look at your go to webinar
control panel
into the questions box you will be able
to ask any questions you want
during the speaker's presentation
let's begin and bring to the show our
first guest
michael walters good morning michael hi
good morning anna
it's a great day today i'm doing good
i'm doing good
you know it's uh it's june already gosh
the time is going by pretty
flies he's current and stuff sure does
or does hopefully uh things will get
back to a normal soon
yeah uh what are you planning to share
with us okay so
you know today um you know i'm going to
be talking about how to use
how to read you know the order flow use
the order flow
to get better trading results you know a
lot of traders
nowadays um sort of
you know are moving towards more towards
automation and and forgetting the
trading part
and i'll show you how you can read
what's happening in the market to
um you know to stay in a trade longer or
get out of a trade earlier
rather than taking the full loss just
take a smaller loss so that's what i'll
be talking about today
so let me get my screen set up here uh
whoops
wrong screen uh
there we go should be okay now should
just see the one screen
yep looks good to me i will get back to
you in 45 minutes
okay great i'll get started now so hey
everyone it's mike waltos from
order flows and welcome today's
presentation you know it's uh
just talking earlier and it's it's kind
of a crazy time that we're in
you know with the coronavirus with all
the protests going on
and you know a lot of people are always
wondering you know how is this going to
affect the markets honestly i talk to a
lot of people he thinks well you know
the market should be down right
shouldn't the markets
be trading around 2000 yet we are you
know trading above 3000 again
and you know it just seems to keep going
higher and higher
and if you're using order flow you know
you would have been on the right side of
a lot of the moves so what are we
talking about today
is how to get better trading results
with
order flow and you know what i'll be
specifically talking about
is order flow market internal data
and when we talk about what it is why
it's important and
how to use that internal data
to nail trades so again you know for
those just really briefly that are new
to
a presentation by myself my name is
michael voltos for the last
five years i've been the owner and
trader at orderflows.com which is a
software
and education company to help traders
understand what's happening in the
market but prior to that my
my professional background is i spent
eight years at jp morgan as vice
president of futures trading
i spent four years with cargill as a
trading desk manager
three years at commerce bank the big
german bank as a licensed ux trader
edf man the big english trading company
for two years as a global macro trader
i spent three years at dean witter i was
a globex trader you know trading
electronic when electronic markets just
started taking off in the mid 90s
and i started my career on the cme
trading floor
as a runner you know back in those days
when there was a trading floor that's
how
a lot of people got into trading is they
would
come down to this the trading floor
either the cme or cbot
or nymex and get a job as as basically
the lowest level but now you don't have
that right now to get a job with the
trading
firm yeah you got to have a math degree
you got to have a programming degree
preferably both you know you got to be
literally a rocket scientist but
um you know so a lot of people don't get
that
entrance into the trading world and then
they start going out there and trying to
figuring things
out for themselves on their own and it's
tough right so that's why i created
orderflows.com and you know sort of the
the
flagship product is the order flows
trader which is a software that runs on
ninjatrader
i created it in 2015 and it runs on
ninjatrader eight and it's a volume
footprint chart with seven
pre-programmed order flow indicators
and you know i just want you to know the
charts that are used in this
presentation
are generated using that order flows
trader
software and you know i wrote a book in
i started writing in 20 late 2013 2014
on trading order flow right and it's
from this book that the order flows.com
and the software um came about but if
you stick around to the end i'll
show you how you get it for free right
it's 150 pages you can download it
you're not going to get sent the hard
copy
now you know just a brief disclaimer
before i jump in i do understand
that trading involves risk right an
investor could potentially lose all or
more than the initial investment
and risk capital's money is money that
can be lost without jeopardizing your
financial security or lifestyle you know
don't don't think that you know you've
got a couple thousand dollars you're
gonna put in a trading account and turn
it into a million dollars in a month
you're not going to do that now let's
jump into it so
markets you know specifically futures
markets you know but forex and stocks
are the same
they trade in a two-way auction there's
a bid and there's an offer
right and people that are sitting on the
bid are what is considered
passive buyers letting the market come
to them right if you're on the offer or
above
the current offer you're what's
considered a passive seller
now for a trade to happen someone's got
to cross the bid off or line
so an aggressive seller has to sell into
the bid
sell to the passive buyer or for the
market to
start moving higher aggressive buyers
have to start buying the offer they have
to start
buying aggressively they have to lift
the offer lift the next offer lift the
next offer
aggressive buyers buy from passive
sellers
but you know interpreting what you see
on the dome or time and sales is like
trying to drink out of a fire hose
right there's just so much information
an order flow footprint chart takes that
information
and puts it into an easy to read and
apply format
you know what you see traded on the dome
is all here but more importantly it puts
it
in a format that you can make informed
trading decisions from
right so you can see you know when
aggressive sellers are in control one
aggressive buyers are in control
when in a bar right within a time period
when it shifted from all aggressive
selling to all aggressive buying
right that's information that as a
trader you know you want to use
and apply in your trading so
after all you know what good is data if
you don't know what to do with it
right so i'm going to talk about sort of
the the three building blocks of order
flow analysis
and their delta point of control and
imbalances it allows you to take you
know
the raw data the raw lego pieces and
build a nice house with
so just really briefly delta is the
difference between aggressive buyers
and aggressive sellers in a bar now
delta's important
is so that you know who is dominating
the current market
as shown in the bar right and again it's
the difference between the volume traded
on the bid
versus the volume traded on the offer
right and delta on my software in most
order flow software
the volume footprint chart goes along
the bottom
right it runs along the bottom some
softwares will put it above or below the
bar
but in general you can see it along the
bottom and you know if your order flow
software doesn't have delta
you should ask you know why doesn't it
have you know this information you know
because it's
you want to know you know is there more
aggressive buying or more aggressive
selling
now point of control is the price level
in the bar
with the most volume you know there's no
fancy mathematical formula
you know or calculus or anything like
that it's just simple arithmetic
you know the bar the price level with
the most volume is traded on the bid and
traded on the offer
if that price level has the most volume
that's your point of control
every bar has a point of control and you
can see i highlighted a few of them here
but generally it will be highlighted
with a rectangle around it some people
like to color it other colors
but generally when you look at it it
stands out right you want to know
where in the bar the most volume
occurred and if you're familiar with
things like volume profile market
profile
you'll understand the importance of
point of control because it can act as
value you know in that bar
in that microstructure
now the third part of order flow is
market imbalances and they occur when
they're
more aggressive buyers and sellers or
vice versa
in the two-way auction so a buying and
balance occurs
when there's at least four times as many
traders buying the offer
than traders selling the bid right so
you gotta have
four to one so you know if the market is
uh
you know 30 19 and a quarter bid at 30
19 and a half
and what traded on the bid was only 10
contracts but
100 contracts traded on the offer that
you'd consider that a buying and balance
because there's more people buying the
offer than selling the bid
by a certain amount right and selling a
balance is the opposite
when there's at least four times as many
traders selling the bid
than traders buying the offer and when
you start seeing these develop right
what you're looking at initially in a on
a footprint chart
is you know one price level but then
when you start seeing
uh aggressive buying at the next price
level the next price level the next
price level
it's telling you that aggressive buyers
are in control
and think of it this way you know i
think of imbalance this way right
you have a big force against a smaller
force who do you think is going to win
the big force is going to win pretty
much majority of the time
and on a footprint chart it's going to
show
you know in the volume in the bar buying
and balances are going to be blue you
can see i highlighted these with blue
arrows i didn't highlight all of them
and selling it balances are red numbers
inside the bar i highlighted
a few of the selling imbalances so you
know generally
as the market rises you see buying
imbalances right you see
aggressive buyers are lifting the best
offer and looking for the next best
offer
you know the band is present right
generally as the market falls you see
selling imbalances you see aggressive
sellers are selling into the best bid
and looking for the nespec's next best
bid
to sell into why is because there's a
lot of supply present right if
there's a lot of supply in the market
they got to start moving it right they
try to start
lowering um their offer they got to
start hitting the bid you know when they
can find buyers they're willing to pay a
certain price they're going to hit those
bids
then they're going to hit the next bid
and hit the next bid until their supply
is gone
now the main topic i want to talk about
is market internal data you know what is
order flow market internal data
so earlier i talked about delta right
which is the difference between
aggressive buyers and aggressive sellers
in a bar and most order flow traders use
delta
in their trading but there are further
distinctions within delta right
there are max delta min delta and
cumulative delta
right so it's not just the headline
delta number which is the
you know the difference at one point but
you also have max min
and cumulative so max delta what that is
is the level at which aggressive buyers
were the strongest in the bar
so meaning a max delta number of 719
tells you that at one point in the bar
there were 719 more
aggressive buys than aggressive cells
now
max delta will always be positive and on
some occasions it may be
zero which means at no point in the bar
we're aggressive buyers
in control okay min delta is the
opposite of max delta
it's the level at which aggressive
sellers were the strongest
in the bar now think of max delta as
buying
min delta as selling okay so a min delta
number of
minus 719 tells you that at one point in
the bar
there were 719 more aggressive sellers
or cells at again one point in the bar
min delta will always be negative right
that's one of the distinctions because
you know when you're calculating just
the delta
right you have your max delta your min
delta max delta is positive min delta is
going to be negative and you know that's
how you you sort of keep the score
so min delta is always going to be
negative and on some occasions it may be
zero meaning that at no point in the bar
were aggressive sellers
in control so on
the volume footprint chart right on like
for example my order flows trader chart
you could put the max delta and min
delta on your chart so you can see
you know what the where the strongest
buying was
where the weakest or the strongest
selling was
and you know most bars you're going to
have generally most bars you're going to
have
you know sort of a tug of war right
you're going to have some max delta
you're going to have some min delta
okay now there's going to be instances
where
you have some bars like you can see
right here right this was yesterday
afternoon
um you know as we made this new high at
29 and a half
there was no min delta right the bar
before
no min delta it's all max delta right
and we close
somewhere near our max delta numbers
okay so i'm going to
get into that a little bit later on why
how to read what's happening
in the max and min delta and the easiest
way to remember
why maxim and delta are
or what they are is the strongest level
aggressive buyers and aggressive sellers
were in a bar
most bars would generally show
aggressive both aggressive buying and
aggressive selling
but there are bars where one side stands
out right all aggressive buying or all
aggressive selling
those are the bars to pay close
attention to in context
of the market like i said you know some
bars most bars are going to have some
positive delta max delta
some min delta but there's going to be
bars
that have either very little min delta
or 0 min delta or very little
max delta or zero max delta
and when you read what's happening in
the market
put it in context of where the market is
trading it can give you some nice
um trading so you know just quickly for
example
okay this is you know
um the second of june which is uh
what tuesday and you can see how the
market popped up right here right it
just
popped up from basically 62 and a half
you know all the way up to 65 and a half
but what preceded it right you had a
couple of bars
he had one bar two bars before that had
zero min delta
the bar immediately before had zero min
delta
but look at the max delta 642 right
and where did the final delta close
right it closed at 642 so it closed on
its extreme buying so i know that
what was happening is you know in these
two bars
right there's very little selling even
though i mean people are trading the bid
but aggressive sellers
aren't in control at any point in this
bar
and then when i see this bar just
dominated by aggressive buying
zero min delta max delta 642
final delta closing on the max number
you know i'm looking for the market to
continue in that direction because i
know i got aggressive buyers
and the beauty is this market really
hasn't started moving yet it's not till
the next bar
where it opens up at you know two and a
quarter trading two and a quarter two
and a half and then boom
over the next five minutes basically
pops up a quick three points
now this is yesterday in the 10-year
note futures you know 10-year notes
are a contract that are extremely
um thick in the sense that a lot of
volume trades on the bid a lot of volume
trades on the offer
you know it's not uncommon as you can
see here to trade
you know several thousand contracts on
the bid and several
thousand on the offer but look what's
happening right this market is just
going sort of sideways
here in this box okay and you're
thinking well yeah you know it looks
like it's kind of coming down but then
when you look at the internals
you just you look at the max delta one
one
zero right here you got back and forth
right this is just your average bar
right you got
303 max delta 407 min delta but here
yeah one one zero and look where
the min delta is 1451 final delta closed
at 1450.
here you've got mid delta of minus 3361.
final delta minus 29.53
this is that mixed bar still negative
you know
minus 407 min delta we close at minus
and then here minus 10 39
0 max delta final delta minus 10 39 so
you're closing
on your extreme here you're closing
within you know one contract of your
extreme here at seven o'clock
here you're closing you know about 300
400 contracts away
but what do you see it's mostly
aggressive
selling brownie i'll say mostly because
you have this bar with a little bit of
progressive buying
but all aggressive selling all
aggressive selling all aggressive
selling what do you think the market's
going to do
right if it can just break through this
this little double bottom here
we're going to drop right and then what
happens in this next bar here right we
trade from
you know the 138 22 and a half area
boom over the next 30 minutes all the
way down to
new lows now people say well yeah that's
only what is that
five um five points
they trade in half ticks in the five
years you know five years is a contract
that people push through a huge size
so if you're just making um you know
four or five ticks in the five years
you're probably trading 10
20 30 contracts that you only need to
make three or four ticks
you know on the fives now cumulative
delta
is the running total of delta on the day
and cumulative delta can be positive
which means there's been more aggressive
buying than selling
and generally the market will be higher
on the day cumulative delta
is negative when cumulative delta is
negative
it means there's been more aggressive
selling up to that point and generally
the market will be lower on the day but
that's not always true i say generally
because the other times where
you know the market has been selling off
all day and
you know we're down negative on the day
then you know the market's going to
start moving up for markets start moving
up you're going to start
seeing cumulative delta getting lesser
and lesser and it could still be
um down on the day but cumulative delta
is turning positive so you know there's
i don't want to give you
you know a statement saying that
cumulative delta is negative means
there's
you know the market is lower on the day
because that's not true you know the
cumulative delta is
dynamic so this is
the footprint chart cumulative delta you
should have on your chart it'll appear
you know on the bottom with your other
delta numbers and it's going to tell you
you can see here right as we hit the
the high of the day right cumulative
delta is its strongest right which is
you know generally how it should be
but i'm going to show you some examples
where you have this divergence when the
market is making new highs but
cumulative delta is getting weaker in
what that means
so every bar has a max delta min delta
and you know cumulative delta is
cumulative up to that point in the bar
and remember max delta can be positive
or it can be
zero min delta is negative or it can be
zero cumulative delta can either be
positive or negative
and on rare occasions it can be
zero okay so
why is this data important is because
you know how many times have you taken a
trade
and immediately it went against you
right it happens to all of us it happens
to me sometimes you know
i think i got the world's greatest trade
setup i get long
market goes up one or two checks and
then really sells off
well it's what you do next what you read
next in the order flow that's going to
determine whether you're going to be
successful or not on the trade
so let me ask you do you let a trade
stop you out or are you willing to get
out of a bad trade early
you know getting out of a bad trade
earlier is going to give you a smaller
loss market internals can tell you when
market conditions change now
you know i'm not saying that as soon as
you know the first sign of a trade not
working out you get out because
you know eventually you know there's
going to be trades where um
you find yourself getting out early and
then the trade goes to a winner but what
i'm saying is you know when
you have a reason for a trade right you
say i'm getting
short because of this reason but then
things in the order flow change you know
as you start moving away from
your entry all right then
the market is telling you you know what
it's discounted already
your your trade idea and you know
chances are
it's not going to work out unless you
still see follow-through order flow
so this is an example um from tuesday
right
market was selling off this is s ps
selling off you know and it looks
negative right you see you're coming
down here you know 30 65 64
63 62 61. then you just get in here you
start forming this base
and if you're watching what's happening
in these deltas
you can see that you know what this
market is starting to turn
so if i'm short okay if i'm short
then i see something happening here in
the deltas max
min delta and to a certain extent
cumulative delta
you know that's my reason to
cut this trade either at a small profit
a small loss at a break even
rather than let it come all the way back
up to my entry and you know
or my stop rather and take a full
loss on it you know that's sort of one
of the drawbacks of
you know a lot of these automated trade
entry systems
all right i don't i get into their names
but you know where
it just you're going to run it on
autopilot you know i've got my take
profit here i've got my stop here
and it's either going to go to my take
profit or it's going to stop me out
well you know at some point all right
you want to be a trader you got to trade
you got to read what's happening in the
market so for example
right this market's coming down but if
i'm watching the delta i see
okay yeah we're here at the low strong
negative delta minus 459
minus 199 minus 13 okay so i know that
the aggressive selling is getting weaker
if i start looking at the internals max
delta is still zero
okay that's what you like to see on a
market going down here
you start to see some buying creep in
positive 53 positive 43
more importantly the min delta minus 774
minus 213 minus 179 so
the min delta is actually getting weaker
as well
so it corresponds to what you're seeing
in the final delta but then
in this nice green bar well you see
min delta's minus one so it's only one
contract
with one you know of aggressive selling
in control of that bar
max delta's 500 right you don't see a
500 in any of these previous bars
and we close right near our
final delta number of 439
okay then yeah maybe you're not
convinced you know you do have a bunch
of bind and balances as well going on in
there which is also bullish
and then in this next bar what do you
got right
min delta zero max delta 443
final delta 313 so you know think about
it what's going on you got aggressive
selling
all the way down here strong aggressive
selling is showing up in the max
i'm sorry the min delta with small max
delta numbers but then you get here
and you can just see the aggressive
selling petering out
minus 774 which are strong within minus
213 minus 179
minus one zero
all right then you start seeing the
max delta growing five one five four
four three
right that's your sign that you know
what i'm short from up here
you know maybe this is time to you know
lighten up on my position
get out of it or you know
take some profits rather than let the
market just slowly grind you because a
lot of times you know people will sit
here and go i'll let the market
yeah this is just a bounce and then
we'll we'll continue down and no if
you're seeing what's happening
in the internals you know that it's
strong off this low
okay so this is um this is yesterday
maximum delta is going to help you see
what direction
we're going in the market so yeah we're
just sort of going sideways here
okay max and min delta is just kind of
going back and forth but you see it's
starting to build up here right you see
you know it's it's a
32 85 142 that's the max delta 85 11 106
86 85 70 182
min delta is kind of strong minus 900
minus 400 minus 300 minus
then it gets in here which is kind of
back and forth minus 100
129 66 54 128 126
152 right you're still putting up
kind of decent mid deltas
but at the same time buying comes in
right what's happening
buyers are absorbing that selling that's
going on until finally
the selling isn't as strong as anymore
right earlier
it was quite strong here right minus 900
minus 400 minus 300
then you just back here you know right
around your your swing low again
but yeah you only got 128 126
152 right the
volume you know isn't that much
different you know 1400
900 800 yeah here you had you know 2
000 but here's fifteen hundred eight
hundred eleven hundred
nine hundred nine hundred and then boom
strong aggressive buying 1689 max delta
1748 next bar 836
we close the final delta also at 8 36
min delta minus 19. it's nothing
right as the market is moving higher now
this was yesterday um you know just
before the cash close
and you know this was very interesting
um what was happening in the market
right you got these new highs right this
is what you like to see at new highs
right big strong positive delta
max delta various you know closing near
your
the final delta closing near your max
delta very small min deltas in these
cases they're zero
but for this market to keep going higher
you want to see the follow through then
in the next bar
it starts out max delta 180
min delta closes at 31 or min delta is
at 316
minus 316. final delta closes at 177.
do you think this market is going higher
or not you know you had the aggressive
buying earlier you had the nice positive
delta earlier
but aggressive sellers took control of
this bar
strong min delta final delta
close negative decent negative minus
177.
say you're still not convinced wait for
the next bar okay this next bar right
here
max delta of one it's nothing there's no
aggressive buyers
min delta minus 822 final delta
minus 445 okay
so you know now yeah that aggressive
selling you know this
honestly in the s ps you get a lot you
know this this algo pop around uh
250 you know 10 minutes for the cash
close um but then
it dries up you don't have that
aggressive buying anymore instead you're
seeing the aggressive selling
and you know you take this you know
quick move from
you know 24 25 all the way down into the
teens
now this is gold right um you know
because a lot of people
look at other markets besides e-minis
but take a look at this bar
right you see the market going down down
down you see this big red bar oh my gosh
we're going lower you know we're going
to trade below 1690.
but what happens all right if you see
this bar
it's got a delta of just minus 13. right
you're
expecting a big down red candle to have
a
you know a big strong negative delta and
at one point
it had a strong min delta minus 203 so
at one point in this bar
the delta number was showing up as -203
but
buying came back in it only closed at
minus -13
so very early in that bar min delta
minus 203
looking very bearish but it ate
all it back you know all the aggressive
buying came in
turn it from minus 203 to just minus 13.
that's bullish right because halfway
through this bar when it was very
bearish
aggressive buyers came in and bought the
market
moved it back higher then the next bar
mostly max delta min delta minus 2
max delta 94 final delta closed at 91
and the next bar to a certain extent min
delta minus 5
you can see 37 max delta
final delta 32 and then obviously in the
next bar
but by this point you know you should
have already been along off of
you know somewhere in this bar or early
in this bar um this one's just all
buying
right you see zero min delta max delta
136 final delta
133. so remember for a market to move in
the direction you expect it to there
needs to be follow through order flow
in the direction you expect the market
to move right because without that
follow through order flow
what reason is there for the market to
move right your super duper indicator
no markets move on the actual buying and
selling taking place
in the market right that's why it's
important to understand
how to read the market internals what's
happening
in the market so
i'm going to take you through a few
examples here on how to use these market
internals to nail trades
you know and you know if if you're
i love that darts the the the
dart world championship you know i i
never really understood a
person when i first saw it on tv years
ago i thought oh gosh this is kind of
lame but
it was actually kind of exciting and you
know trading should be exciting for you
right and being able to use your skill
as a traders is the same as you know
being a
professional athlete and you know being
able to
score or you know throw the darts and
get 180
and you know or put the ball in the back
of the net and you know that that's what
trading is all about putting the ball in
the back of the net
so this was monday
on the s ps the e-minis and you know we
were making these new highs
you know from 55 all the way up to 59
and so there are some shorting
opportunities you know i label them here
a b
c d um and potentially e
so in this case you know you want to be
watching what's happening in the deltas
right the
the max delta the min delta the
cumulative delta so
i'm going to go through it easy here so
i'll talk about the cumulative delta
so you have point a cumulative delta was
636 point b 9875
point c 10 5 36
okay you know at point a
you got a nice strong positive
cumulative delta
point b delta's a little bit weaker okay
it's only 900 okay now point c it's back
up to 10
500 okay this point c point d
it's ten thousand four eighty and by
point e i didn't label it there was
that's the red arrow
you know it's it's back below ten
thousand
so think about it what's going on right
this market is going higher
okay ten thirty ten point a ten thousand
six thirty six cumulative delta point b
a new higher high
but less delta okay it's a sign the
market
is getting weaker but again if you
shorted that right you got to be
watching what's happening
in the order flow right go back here so
9875 okay you say you get short here
okay you get short does the market sell
off
no it just goes sideways okay when the
market's going sideways
that's not a good sign when you're in a
trade you know for me i let
like to expect the market to move within
two ticks
or sorry within two bars after getting
uh
you know taking a trade um
and as many as five bars so between two
to five
is my target right if the market is not
moving down if i'm short and the
market's not moving down here
so say i'm short immediately here right
right at the low of this
this bar here right after this bar
closes at 54
and a quarter one two it's back up to 55
and a half
you know three four five you know this
is my sign to get out
but more importantly i got to be
watching what's happening you know in
the delta by the time i get back here
delta's grown back up to ten thousand
okay
yeah i'm fine take my loss okay i'm
going to wait for the next trade
so market goes back up a new high a nice
positive delta again it's not high it's
10536 at point c
it's higher than b but you know it's
it's 100 contracts less than point a but
i'm not going to split hairs it's it's
relatively the same d
again still about the same but again you
know i just rallied four points from 55
up to 59 delta is still about the same
so what's that telling you
right it's telling you that you know
there's even those aggressive buying
there's also aggressive selling right
you should
you should have a big positive jump in
the cumulative delta
you know by between point a to point d
you know
h 10636 point d yeah you want it to be
at least you know 11
000. i'm not going to say hard and fast
it should be you know 500 contracts more
but it should be more
not about the same then as you start
going sideways in here
it loses that delta cumulative delta ten
thousand four
eighty getting to the point e and here
it's only nine thousand nine hundred so
where's the strength in the market right
it's not there
so if again if you're looking for this
market to break out
it's probably not going to happen
instead the trade is probably going to
be to the short side
rather than to the long side and what
happens
the market sold off
so anytime you're up at new highs right
you've got to watch the cumulative delta
is there strength or weakness showing
right so you can see here right nineteen
thousand the first arrow cumulative
delta nineteen thousand four hundred
second arrow nineteen thousand five
hundred
third arrow twenty thousand four hundred
so yeah cumulative delta is expanding
more positive that's what you want to
see on a market that's going to be
trending higher
right not cumulative delta just sort of
hanging around the same level
and then losing you know some of that
delta
as you're at the high of the day all
right you want to be seen
for a market to keep going up you're
going to be expecting cumulative delta
to keep rising right now
this is on tuesday in the s ps this was
right after the cash open and this was
very interesting
cash opened on tuesday
sold off down to this you know 51 and
three-quarter area
bounced back up and looked like it was
starting to sell off right you see the
negative delta here in this red bar
minus eight sixty one
minus thirteen hundred minus nine eighty
two three big strong
red bars down max delta twenty eight
only zero twenty eight min delta minus
nine sixty six
minus fifteen hundred minus a thousand
and we're closing our final deltas right
around those numbers
and then this green bar opens up minus
eight hundred and forty
on the min delta so this delta number is
showing
minus 840 okay
right here but then what happens in this
bar
it reversed it went from minus 840
to positive 412 max delta min delta
minus 840 max delta 412.
we closed at 355. so it is actually a
swing of -840 to positive
400. so that's you know a swing of 1200
contracts from
very strong min delta to strong
max delta so it's telling me this
market's not going lower even though
these three bars very bearish
right that's your sign to get long and
then the market boom
you know immediately moved up from 55
above 60.
this is a bonds it's a five-minute chart
this is yesterday
excuse me
so what do you see again you know
sometimes you know trading the market's
got to be a little bit
detective right okay the market is
popping up going a little bit higher
here
you can see mostly max delta in these
three bars here 42
30 56 so final delta is positives
you can see max delta 117 versus zero 71
versus
minus five 586 versus zero okay
yeah maybe this market go higher but
then it sort of
drops off a little bit and goes sideways
okay but when we're going sideways what
are you seeing
yeah you see min negative deltas minus 2
2 1 minus 29
minus 175 minus 17 minus 316 but look at
the max delta
very little aggressive buying
zero sixteen zero zero zero so when i
say
very little aggressive buying in the max
delta what i mean is aggressive buyers
weren't in control in four out of five
of these bars even though there's some
volume traded on the offer it's not
enough to turn
the delta positive except this one case
it's got small delta
of minus 29 there was 16 but everything
else zero zero zero
min delta minus 280 minus 62 minus 238
minus 62 minus 335 right
and then the next two bars you know this
next bar
zero min delta all max delta and then
min delta max delta
positive delta but looking at these bars
in here
which direction do you think the market
is going to go going to go up we're
going to go down
right it's more inclined it's telling me
it went sideways in here
and there was supply coming into the
market okay
if you're ever trading institutionally
and you got a lot of supply
you're going to know that you don't want
to put your foot on the gas pedal right
you sell some
you let the market pause this is that
pause then you sell some more
right so you see how the market dropped
from you know the 26 area down into new
lows
at 06 at 05.
so order flow analysis provides the
trader advanced information that they
need
to gain an edge over other traders right
order flow allows you to see and
undersea
understand what is happening in the
markets that and
other traders just don't see right so
hopefully you can see how powerful order
flow trading
is right don't over complicate trading
trade what's happening right in front of
you
so if you found this helpful i hope you
did you'll really like my order flows
trader 2.0 software package which makes
overflow analysis very easy
so you know who wants to learn order
flow
analysis and add it to their trading so
there's two ways
one you could do it on your own you
could spend a year looking at a chart
trying to figure out order flow
you wasted you're losing more money
trading basically and when i ask you a
year later from now you know when you
attend one of my presentations or watch
a video
and i ask you how your training is going
you know you're gonna look like rambo
or number two get the education and
software from a trader
who has successfully traded order flow
at the highest level for literally
decades you know skip the massive
trading losses skip the wasted
time and the way i'd like to describe it
is you know imagine you're you're
at disneyland with your family and
mickey mouse comes up to you
and says hey come with me go to the
front of the line
that's what i'm offering you today you
know the order flows trader 2.0 for
ninjatrader 8.
we're probably going to have it
overflows 3.0 um
later this summer it's several months
away so don't don't email me asking for
the upgrade now because it's it's
probably not until
august or september and it's going to be
a free upgrade
and it works on ninjatrader 8. it
doesn't work on thinkorswim doesn't work
on tradestation it's on the ninjatrader
and it'll work on the free version is
the volume footprint chart that you saw
generated with these charts in here in
this presentation
there's seven pre-programmed overflow
indicators i didn't even talk about
those today i just talked about the
simple deltas
you're gonna get my chart template and
normally this is 899
but having order flow software is one
thing the next thing is knowing how to
use it
i just don't give you the software send
you on your way i provide you a lot of
education on how to trade
order flow and for example one of the
things that i offer
when you get my software is i do a
weekly
live group training session for users
it's on tuesday nights now used to be
monday but it's tuesday now
and if you can't attend you can watch
the recordings and again you know
there's some people out there that you
know
you spend two thousand dollars on your
software then you want to join the group
you've got to pay another 200 bucks a
month you know what for
you know first of all i don't charge
that amount and you know for a weekly
group training
you know where you could ask questions
that's free it should be free
but i'm also going to give you the order
flows trading course which i normally
sell for 297 on my website
i'll give you access to my order flows
inner circle video series which
is 56 videos on advanced order flow
training
tips tricks and analysis so you put all
that together
it's you know close to seventeen hundred
dollars that the software the training
the live training
um the inner circle and as a special
bonus because of
investors expo i'll give you access to
my favorite course that i created the
order flows playbook
so you add that up it's close to two
thousand dollars
and you know other traders have got my
software
and they see that how helpful it is you
know they post it you know mike this
software is remarkably helpful
i can clearly see now what's happening
in the market on a very specific time
and who's getting weaker as well you
know other people say
um you know posting comments on my
videos
you give really fresh insane air in the
field very impressive
very rare so time to think about success
right is the plan
then you're going to reach success you
know being a successful trader so it's
not going to fall in your lap
so you get all this stuff for just a
one-time payment of 6.75
so go to orderflows.com the the link is
in the chat
there there's no monthly payments no
other payments in the future so
you know you're good to go right and
that's how it should be in
you know in trading right you want to
get started as as fast as you can
so go to orderflows.com off to it's
going to take you to this page
just scroll down takes it to this button
buy now i want this
right it's processed by paypal i don't
deal with your credit card i don't want
it
so just go through that and then you
know within
an hour or two or so depending on how
long it takes to process your payment to
get processed
you're done i'll send you all the
information now if you want my book go
to
dot orderflows.combook.html you gotta
enter your name and email address and
it'll take you to the download page
after
so you know if act now it's a you know
it's a
cliche act now but really you know if
you want to become a successful trader
you got to take action all right you got
to take that step forward
and and get from point a to point b
as quickly as possible so
you know that's all i've got for you
today so anna i'm going to throw it back
to you i don't have time for questions
but you know anybody's got any questions
just shoot me an email
mike orderflows.com but anna i'll throw
it back to you
right now thank you so much michael okay
you're welcome
let's move on in prince of the show our
next presenter
eric gephardt hi